shauna burgess is officially a mom the
dancing with the stars pro dancer and
her beau brian austin green are
officially parents to a baby boy
hey baby
i can't believe this is for real
happening crazy i am unbelievably
excited to share with him something i
love so deeply sharna and brian first
confirmed the pregnancy news in february
during a trip in hawaii to have a real
relationship and to have that chemistry
that's not you're not trying to create
it for the show it's there later that
month in an instagram caption she wrote
and suddenly my world would never be the
same forever greater forever expanded
and deeper forever abundant and
unconditional love baby boy july 4th ish
2022 the pair first started dating in
2020. i'm excited that she's in my life
and uh i
i i think she's amazing this is sharna's
first child and brian's fifth he shares
three sons with ex-wife megan fox
journey bodhi and noah it's 15 amazing
years that we spent together and three
amazing kids
um
and she helped me raise
raised cassius who's now 18.
um
so she's she's always been around i've
i've known her for a long time she's
known me for a long time brian has also
dad to cassius with actress vanessa
marcel sharna opened up to e.t about her
hopes of becoming a mother one day last
june kids have always been on the cards
for me 100 they've always been on the
cards for me um so
you know we'll see what the universe
says will happen yeah we're just gonna
leave that open at the time brian also
shared that his kids are bonding with
her she's great with him she really is
she's
she's super fun they love
they love hanging out with her and doing
things and she has a great connection
with each one of them but she's also
uh she just
instinctually sort of knows how to
not be a step not be a step parent in
that way but like really
just bond with them and love them and
they feel really safe with her and it
and it's it's an amazing connection that
they have and she again she has it with
all three of them on their own so she
she knows
she really knows what each one likes and
does it and she uh she walks the line
really well
i love her
feelings are mutual they're really cool
little humans you know and i it's just
becoming good friends with them you know
knowing what they like and playing with
them and having a good time and they're
they're you know way more about
dinosaurs than you knew before i know
the names of dinosaurs like for a really
big year yeah i'm not really into
dinosaurs yeah
but no it's it's been really really cool
i've always loved kids i love you know
teaching kids and i've worked with kids
a lot a lot of my friends have kids now
and i'm obsessed with them so uh it's it
was really wonderful for me to be able
to connect with them congratulations to
the happy couple on their new bundle of
joy